new surveillance video may give
investigators fresh clues into the
disappearance of two kids in Idaho their
mother and stepfather a considered
persons of interest but have not been
arrested or charged the video appears to
show their mother that's lori valo at a
storage facility near their home shortly
after the boy and girl were last seen in
September Jonathan Vigliotti is at the
facility in Rexburg Idaho with more on
this story Jonathan good morning to you
what are police saying about this video
Gale good morning to you in a search
that has produced very little what was
found inside this storage facility is
being considered a breakthrough of sorts
investigators we are told have come
through it what they have found at this
point remains unclear listen it's not
unusual for a family to rent a unit of
this kind before making a big move like
they did before going to Hawaii but what
remains a mystery this morning why most
of the things found inside almost
exclusively belong to the two missing
children
surveillance video appears to show lori
valo and a man visiting the storage unit
on multiple occasions last fall it was
just after the September disappearance
of her seven-year-old adopted son JJ and
17 year old daughter Kylie Ryan at one
point a man has seen carrying out a
heavy tote bag inside the unit police
found bikes photos and a backpack with
JJ's initials it was disturbing to see
that it was the children's belongings
that were in that storage unit rich
Robertson is a private investigator
working with JJ's grandparents ka-larry
Woodcock if they had expected the kids
to be coming home soon why would that
stuff be in the storage on the other
hand if they didn't think the kids were
ever coming back why keep it Wednesday
the Woodcock's filed a petition to
obtain guardianship of JJ K attended a
press conference last week after a Valu
ignored a court order to produce the two
kids everybody has to be accountable if
you're not accountable to the law then
you're accountable to God why don't you
give us answers
valo and her husband Chad de Bell were
last seen in Hawaii in the past eight
months
the couple's former spouses and that
those brother all died under what
authorities say are suspicious
circumstances
the private investigator says Val owes
ex-husband Charles whose death is under
investigation had a million-dollar
life-insurance policy at this point we
think that Lorie Vala believes she was
the beneficiary and a legal expert tells
us a lack of evidence maybe why this
couple has not been arrested they could
face a contempt charge for failing to
produce their children but even that may
not be enough to require them to come
back here to Idaho meanwhile this couple
maintaining their innocence saying there
has been no wrongdoing
Anthony such a strange case and we hope
they find those kids Jonathan thank you